this morning on the dish chef Anthony
Sasso he was born in the Hudson River
Valley of New York to a family with
roots in Spain after culinary school in
New York City and jobs at some of the
city's top restaurants he travelled to
Spain to master its secrets he brought
that knowledge back to New York's Casa
mano where he earned five consecutive
Michelin stars this year he became
executive chef at tapas bar at La Serena
in Chelsea's maritime hotel the main
restaurant is all Italian a project of
Mario Batali and Joseph basi homage but
the bar is all his featuring an entirely
separate menu of small Spanish dishes
perfect I might say with drinks chef
Anthony Sasso good morning welcome to
the dish good morning
I think we're looking at half of that
menu right now some of what you can tell
us that's here well the big attraction
there's the pyah pyah is one thing that
we can do at Serena that we weren't able
to Casa moto
the restaurant is probably ten times the
size the kitchen is you know 20 times
the size of the old Russia that I came
from but that's definitely one of the
anchors of Spanish cuisine and the fun
thing about it in Serina is we're
serving this alongside in a different
room right next to some of the best
pastas in the city so it's a really fun
concept that we started about six months
ago and it's really taken off you know a
lot of the chef's we've had here grow up
and they've got a family that's inspired
them and so many ways to cook and you
sort of said that it was you know trial
and error on your own early on yeah I
mean I always had fun in the kitchen and
playing around my father's a carpenter
so he was really good with his hands and
building and my mom always had a way to
kind of like work two jobs or three jobs
just to kind of like keep everything
else together so me and my three sisters
we were stuck in a kitchen and kind of
like had to fend for ourselves a little
bit as far as like making dinner we had
grandmother's nose clear close by that
always kind of like had something on the
stove that we would either pitch in and
eat or help them kind of like wrap up
together for dinner time so whatever the
lightbulb go offer you that this was
what you wanted to do I think it was it
was right about that time when the Food
Network was really taking off so you
were able to see these chefs in their
kitchens put together their job outside
the restaurant and I got really into it
I lot of my first jobs were in kitchens
and restaurants
and I loved it I just always write
really write names I mean Bobby Flay
Wylie Dufresne Mario Batali right so as
a young cook that's kind of like what
you're going for you going for the best
in the in the business and then I
mentioned you went to Spain to learn as
well what was that experience like for
you well I wouldn't Spain the first few
times I went there was just to kind of
like travel and to see my family so my
first day there one of these trips my
uncle brought me said his favorite
restaurant and you know I had bought a
one-way ticket that trip and didn't know
if I was ever going to come back home
and the second day I walked in the
kitchen and met the chef and the third
day I had a job and I said I ended up
staying for a full year that time the
tapas which everybody knows from Spain
now a part of laughs arena that's not a
common thing it's like a restaurant
within a restaurant how did that concept
even come across so I had kind I had
been customer for a very long time it
was kind of like this little place that
I won't say was containing B but I think
that's the way like Mario Batali looked
at he was kind of like how do we give
him a larger platform right we made you
an offer you couldn't refuse okay and
the way he made it was kind of Godfather
asked where we two of us met alone not a
horse had involved was there maybe a
pig's head we met at his restaurant odo
kind of in the back of this empty room
it was nine o'clock in the morning we
were the only two there so he kind of
said I want to do something with this
huge space that I have that's kind of we
should be used for multiple purposes so
he asked me if I wanted to come over I
offer tapas food in his Italian
restaurant in the bar area so did you
say yes right away
no so I had Mona's very endearing to me
I've been there for a long time so he
basically gave me a night to think about
it he was like I'll just give me an
answer tomorrow morning he called me
back four hours later it was like so
what are you gonna do and I mean at that
point I was just like yes I'm on board I
think it's a great idea there's a great
marriage we are on the dish so I will
ask you to sign our dish I'm not used to
plates these large let me ask you this
as well if you could have a meal anyone
past or present who would it be my
grandmother Nonya she passed away not
that long ago it was her food that kind
of got me into cooking and I still think
about what she would put on a play
whenever I'm thinking of putting
something on the plate myself so you see
it in the cuisine as well a little love
in there thank you so much yes chef
Anthony Sasso for more on him and the
dish you can head to our website at CBS
this morning dot-com